whatever happened to Anna Paquin after
escaping all the fang-banger Sperrys and
werepanthers of all tall here's a look
at what she's been up to lately small
screen complications after True Blood
Pack 1 booked a couple of TV guest roles
but it still took a few years for her to
return to the small screen in any
regular capacity she took the lead in
the 2017 Canadian series Bellevue and
while the show was well received by
critics it was still canceled by CBC
after just one season Paquin went on to
star in Netflix's adaptation of Margaret
Atwood's novel alias grace but it didn't
receive the same fanfare as The
Handmaid's Tale another recent Atwood
adaptation and since alias grace was
billed as a limited series there are few
hopes of a second season renewal in
other words while Paquin has continued
to pursue work on the medium that made
her a household name she hasn't yet
enjoyed the type of breakout role she
had with True Blood no healing power
prior to True Blood Pack 1 is perhaps
best known for her work as rogue in the
x-men film series she starred in the
original trilogy and was among the cast
members invited to come back to the
rebooted franchise for 2014 x-men Days
of Future past unfortunately her scenes
were ultimately edited from the film's
theatrical version and only made it to
screens by way of an expanded rogue cut
assembled for home video director Bryan
Singer cited the film's length and
crowded plot as his reasons for cutting
the scenes being axed from a successful
blockbuster certainly didn't help to
elevate Paquin's profile even if some
consider the rogue cut the best version
of the film Pixar's rare miss one year
after Days of Future Passed Paquin
starred is the tough t-rex Ramsay and
Pixar's the good dinosaur
despite the studio's long-running track
record the film was largely ignored by
audiences and given a comparatively
ho-hum reception by critics as well this
is my personal bubble Paquin was hardly
to blame for the good dinosaurs bad
results as the film's production was
famously fraught with problems
even so suffering through two major let
downs while working on two large-scale
studio films had to be a bit
demoralizing fighting the Marazzi
machine another reason Paquin may have
taken a step back from the spotlight in
recent years is that she's fiercely
protective of her children twin
Charlie and poppy she and her husband
True Blood co-star Stephen Moyer welcome
the pair into the world in 2013 and
she's made a very concerted effort to
guard their privacy I mean they kind of
get the concept kissed they'll seen
pictures of me or their dad doing daddy
considering Paquin started working at
the age of nine she's especially
familiar with how unkind the limelight
can be for kids
she told today in 2018 you won't find
any pictures of my children that's a
choice we made very specifically I want
the right to say that they're not fair
game another reason to advocate in
addition to sticking up for her little
ones Paquin has also been very vocal on
her own behalf in 2010 she publicly
revealed that she's bisexual appearing
in a public service announcement for the
give a damn campaign alongside other
celebrities to promote LGBTQ rights and
awareness because one hate crime is
committed approximately every hour of
every day in this country soon after she
found the subject coming up repeatedly
in interviews so she felt it was
important to help spread awareness for
bisexuality on behalf of an often
misunderstood community
she's emerged as a major advocate for
equal rights promoting the no hate
campaign alongside her husband who is
openly supported her reteaming with
hubby in 2014 Paquin and Moyer joined
forces to start up their own production
company Kasim films they landed in
familiar territory almost immediately
with a first-look development deal at
HBO
the endeavor might not have resulted in
them reuniting for another romp through
the mystical wilderness but the company
has allowed them to explore some other
territory mm 18s the parting glass was
directed by Moyer while Paquin who
co-produced starred in the picture it
was based on a script from the pair's
fellow True Blood alum Dennis of hair
who also appears in the film the newest
move for pact when in chasm films is a
British television series called flack
which will feature her as an American
public relations executive tried to hack
it in London like most of her recent TV
work the series is expected to be short
with an initial order for just six
episodes returning to the big time
although Paquin's been comparatively
under the radar lately that's likely to
change in the very near future she stars
alongside Robert De Niro and Martin
Scorsese's upcoming gangster drama the
Richmond a project she's described as
being directly in her wheelhouse
in the film Paquin portrays Peggy
daughter of Frank the Irishman Sharon
the mafioso who claimed to assassinate
Jimmy Hoffa the film completed
production in March 2018 and is expected
to debut on Netflix in 2019
[Music]